it wouldn't be fair to say that a lot of
these young kids like this is the dream
right when I was growing up it was like
hey I want to go play in the NBA or play
for professional sports people maybe
wanted to be like a traditional actor or
a musician it feels like now there's a
lot of these kids were saying like no I
actually want to be an influence or like
that is something to aspire to be as a
career yeah absolutely I think it's like
the number one thing a lot of kids
aspire to be I saw some stupid thing
that was going around last year of like
oh and some other country kids want to
be an astronaut in America they want to
be a youtuber and you know people will
share that and they sort of joke about
it which I get but you know if you're a
youtuber well one that's that's the work
that you're seeing modeled everyday you
know when you log on the Internet
you're following people that you know
these that are talking about their job
every day like you know these youtubers
are talking about what it's like to be a
youtuber how they're making money you
know they'll give a behind-the-scenes
tour of like you know the the factory
that's developing their merch or things
like that so they're talking about that
career in a really detailed way to kids
in a way that honest idiot a lot of kids
don't have any clue what their parents
do but they they deeply understand sort
of like how an influencer business works
um so that's part of it I think is why
they think it's aspirational it's it's
the main version of work that they're
seeing on the internet every day and
then to UM you know there's a huge
amount of autonomy that comes with
running your own business um a lot of
people mistake wanting to be an
influencer or with wanting Fame um but a
lot of these kids what they want is they
want autonomy and they want to be able
to run their own company based off their
own interests so if you know if you can
run a small business that's you know
gets you access to certain events maybe
because you know you you're involved in
some world you know I'll use cars is
another example because I know this this
kid I can't remember his name but he was
on YouTube he's very into cars right
like you know in the past maybe he would
have been a car journalist to be honest
but you know he makes all of these
really cool driving videos he gets to
test cars before anyone else he gets to
work with all these major car brands
that's a dream job you know um and you
own your income
you set your own hours you have enormous
flexibility I can't imagine why you
would want to do you know some
entry-level job and instead of sort of
owning your own thing yeah it's almost
like the barriers to entry are so low
because literally you know you've got a
cellphone in your hand can you record a
video post it on one of these platforms
and if you're good at it all of a sudden
you can gain the audience and it goes
from there
and another piece that you know in
conversations I have with people who are
trying to understand this stuff I always
say like this isn't new either right I
mean if you look at Oprah Tony Robbins
and all these people basically were the
influencers before we called them
influencers they just had to do it on
different platforms it took a lot more
capital and that do most of these
younger kids understand that kind of
this isn't new
it's just in a new form factor or they
just so focused on what they're doing
that they don't really kind of make the
historical connection yeah I mean I
think Oprah is different because she's
more of a traditional celebrity and so
there's all these sort of gatekeepers
right before getting there and I don't
think that she really owned her own IP
and business from the start
Tony Robbins might be a better example I
mean I think some people in certain
careers right he's an entrepreneur
ultimately um so yeah I think that
what's different is that you know it's
people building themselves up on this
digital platforms and sort of owning
their followers um and you're right that
is not new I mean it's funny when I did
this story recently on agency as I was
talking to this guy from Abrams which
was a big sort of talent agency and they
were signing MySpace stars back in 2006
um so I think it took a while for it to
emerge I mean I got my start on tumblr
and you know there were certainly other
people that were very big on tumblr at
the time that I was that have sort of
launched careers from that um but it's
just it's more pervasive now I think you
know every year kids are more and more
sort of on the internet these social
platforms get more power and so I think
that it sort of progressed into
mainstream culture in a different way
just the fact that I have a job covering
this stuff you know I couldn't get a job
I tried for a long time to write about
this stuff full-time and there really
wasn't an audience I would say until
three years ago so you know I think it's
entering the mainstream in a different
way
yeah